well thank you and it is a pleasure and
honor for me to be here I have been
involved in this topic for the past two
decades it is a very controversial topic
I was very impressed with the questions
that
caromed forwarded to me that you had put
forth and we're going to talk about some
of those a little bit and my preference
and given a presentation is for it to be
very informal and if it's okay with
these two people here if there are
questions as we go along please feel
free to interrupt me and we'll have a
discussion
I actually prefer that type of format I
have not been to Yale before but one
thing that I see is that students don't
sit in the front just like they don't
set it in front at NC State where I
teach so I'm used to that I'm going to
talk about several topics this afternoon
primarily related to the issues
surrounding animal production
agriculture I know that the topic in
your module is beef I have very little
experience with beef but I will tell you
that the issues related to the
environmental component are almost the
same and I'm going to talk about that a
little bit I have a lot of colleagues at
other institutions that have spent their
career on waste management issues
related to beat production especially
colleagues at Texas A&M and and parts of
the Midwest but again the the societal
and the environmental the sustained
sustainability issues are the same and I
hope that I can make that point with you
this afternoon one thing that I want to
start
is making a distinction between animal
feeding operations and concentrated
animal feeding operations you see this
misrepresented repeatedly and actually
the peer-reviewed scientific literature
and I kind of hate to admit it but I am
a co-author on a paper now with some
people that Duke University where we
have looked at the impact of estrogens
from livestock operations on the
environment fate and transport and the
facility that we use is clearly an
animal feeding operation it is not a
concentrated animal feeding operation
but my colleagues on that paper are
insisting that we continue to keep the
term CAFO in the paper because that is
what everyone identifies with but I want
you to be aware of the distinction and
this is an EPA rules animal feeding
operations are operations where the
animals are kept and raised in confined
situations feed is brought in to the
animals rather than the animals grazing
or consume and feed that has grown in
that area and jumping ahead a little bit
and and this is an area and I told Carol
make when she contacted me about this
several months ago
that I'm someone that gets yelled at by
both sides I get yelled at a lot by the
environmentalists I get yelled at a lot
by the industry and I think you'll see
why that's apparent as we go through the
presentation and as long as I'm being
yelled at by both sides I'm okay with
that but from a sustainable issue which
one component of what you're talking
about in this course a lot of the animal
feeding operations and concentrated
animal feeding operations bring the free
feed in from outside and the meat
product goes to the consumer often
outside of that area most often outside
of that area in North Carolina
the East Coast Cardiff is the Northeast
Corridor is a big customer based area
for the meat that is produced in North
Carolina but with the feed coming in to
North Carolina and the waste products
staying close to where the animals are
produced that is not a sustainable
situation so just jumping ahead a little
bit feed is brought in and by definition
an animal feeding operation is under
that environmental condition for a total
of 45 days or more in any 12-month
period it is not the calendar year
there's a consecutive 12-month period
and crops vegetation forage growth or
post harvest residues are not maintained
in that area that is an animal feeding
operation now EPA identifies a
concentrated animal feeding operation is
one in which essentially has these
numbers for these animal sectors and for
your group you are interested in cattle
so anything that would be a thousand
head or more would be a concentrated
animal feeding operation if it is indeed
and trust me it will be a CAFO but it
first has to be rather than a fill it
first has to be an AFO before it can be
a CAFO now what you will see and this is
the case what whatever what whatever it
is within that permitted unit okay so it
would be within a unit that would that
would have the permit so what you will
often see and where we were doing the
estrogen study it was on a swine
operation and and this is not uncommon
you will see a lot of these animal units
that will have just below this threshold
this is where it will be designed for
and this will be the number that was
maintained on ours with the with the
swine operation I think the facility
that we did the study they were
permitted for 2,400 animals and I think
you can understand the logic of that
they don't want to be characterized into
that CAFO because more so in the past
than now although this can always change
the regulations if you are a CAFO are
significantly different or can be
significantly different as compared to
an a fund now and one time EPA intended
for all of these operations that were
would be in this category to be required
to have an NPDES permit that is that has
gone through the court system repeatedly
over the past decade EPA has been sued
by both the industry as well as the
environmental groups on that topic
currently there is no requirement to
have an NPDES permit even if you have
this number of animals or more unless
you are found to be discharging to
surface waters of that state and that is
a violation of the Clean Water Act and
they have been back and forth about this
and but that's where it currently stands
now you do not have to have NPDES unless
you're discharged if you're found to be
discharging yes they're going to put you
under the requirement of having that
permit and that's where the medium and
small k flows come into characterization
these units do not require even under
the earlier laws where EPA wanted
everyone to have an NPDES that would be
in this category these are not required
to have that but they would be if they
were found to be in violation relative
to discharge of animal waste residues to
surface waters so you
you are a small CAFO and you get a call
from MPD from EPA that you are required
to do an NPDES because you have been
found to be in violation that is a very
very bad day for you so that's we could
talk I teach three lectures on these
regulations in a course that I teach
every fall and it's very complex but I
want you to be aware of these
differences and the basis of why so
hopes before I go to that did they have
the slides in advance okay so when I'm
on an airplane and the person next to
you you says okay what do you do and I
tell them the tight work I do and then I
start they say well what does that
involve and I start talking about some
of these numbers most of the people in
society are just absolutely
flabbergasted by these numbers so if I
ask you on a day-to-day basis in the
u.s. how many head of cattle your unit
is cattle are on the ground in the u.s.
approximately anyone else he got it
almost exactly right it's about 100
million
what about swine anyone want to put
forth a guess day to day inventory swine
we have 10 million now 50 you got the
first one right what do you think was
swine
you're right again
you're right again so a hundred
approximately 100 day-to-day inventory
let's talk about poultry a little bit me
type chickens
how many 100 million we have and this is
this would be I want to go back a little
bit before the meat type chickens let's
do the number that are produced annually
in the US that are put into the
cellophane in the market and go to the
the the KFC's and that those type places
how many per year in the US only 800 got
a billion anyone else I've heard a
billion as the highest it's about eight
point five billion table eggs table eggs
that we have i I had a couple boiled
eggs for breakfast this morning
how many table eggs per year how many 80
billion so 80 billion and this is only
in the u.s. this is only in the u.s.
yeah and I want to make clearly the
young man was correct on the day-to-day
inventory on cattle but these are actual
production this is this would be
approximately slaughter number and I
actually think this number is a little
bit low but I got this from the American
Meat Institute and they're usually
pretty spot-on with with their numbers
they're pretty objective we see little
over 100 million hogs eight point five
billion head of chickens eighty billion
eggs if you consider the economics and
you have yes question
that's correct that that is correct
good point and I also didn't put turkeys
in this this slide as well we grow a lot
of turkeys in North Carolina but if you
look at all livestock and poultry in the
the dairy and the turkeys and the ones
that I don't have here the that industry
employs about 6 million people in the US
and is responsible for about 900 billion
annually to the US economy that's the
high percent of the the GU the profit
gross national product now but I want
you to make sure that you understand
this is all of the allied industries
this is from the farm gate and allied
industries that get the products into
the consumer market so it's the big
industry question back to the early if
you just look at this block here is this
an animal feeding operation if you just
look at that the visual there is that an
animal feeding operation well the the
cover crop is being pretty well
maintained so this actually would not be
if you just look at this photo
that would not be an AFO
oh yeah absolutely absolutely and they
probably are it especially was in this
photo how about this absolutely
so the state that I'm from yes sir I I
don't have that in the presentation
today but I have seen that data that
data is available oh there's no question
about that oh okay now and now I better
understand your question and I will go
into this a little bit later because I
know the multiplier because I I'm not an
economist but I work with a lot of
economists so in North Carolina the
state that I'm from North Carolina is
often referred to as a number one meat
producing state in the nation and I'm
not sure if that's true or not but we we
certainly produce a lot of livestock and
poultry in North Carolina about 800
million chickens 35 million turkeys 3.1
billion table legs and 18 million hogs
per year the day-to-day inventory of
hogs in North Carolina is about 10
million thus more we don't have that
many people in North Carolina it it
would for the industry it would be for
the breeder flocks and those numbers are
tremendous as well good question
so what is length define that a beef of
swine eating chicken are needed to grow
because you said that there's only if
you look at the day-to-day inventory if
it's just less than double for that and
and for chickens it's every six to seven
weeks right because you've got to
maintain those flocks
so this is where we look at the the
economic aspect a little more
specifically for a specific case in
North Carolina and this will answer the
the prior question to some degree the
farm gate income for all agricultural
commodities livestock poultry crop
greenhouse including tobacco at one time
tobacco was a big industry in North
Carolina it is not such a big industry
now but livestock and poultry represent
approximately 65% of the total
agricultural economy in the state so 65%
of this total value of farm gate value
is going to be from animal production
agriculture now the economists tell me
and this this would be the revenue that
would go to the producers The
Economist's tell me that you can
conservatively multiply farm gate by a
factor of four to five to get the total
economic impact of getting the product
to the consumer
now an interesting situation and this
relates to sustainability it relates to
I think the topic of your course if you
look at what has occurred in North
Carolina in 1991 the day-to-day
inventory was about three million pigs
on the ground and then that rapidly grew
over a period of just five to six years
to a day-to-day inventory of
approximately ten million and it has
plateaued since then because of policy
that was implemented in the state of
North Carolina which put a moratorium on
expanding that industry and the
moratorium was based on environmental
concerns and exceptions to the
moratorium require that remediation
technologies be implemented that address
specific environmental parameters and we
will be talking specifically about that
because I've spent a lot of time in the
past two decades on that specific topic
and again the technologies overlap to
poultry beef dairy they overlap and
we'll talk about that had a question
here
it does not it does not that's an
interesting question because the
political makeup of our legislature in
North Carolina has changed significantly
in the last two years are you told me
you're from Western Salem right so you
probably know a little bit about this
and they're actually there have been
some discussions in some stakeholder
groups that the law that was implemented
here could possibly be repealed so that
would be an expiration but but it
doesn't have the only restrictions
the only criteria associated with the
moratorium now is that you have to have
a technology that meets the criteria
that are defined which we will talk
about and if I'd had a little more time
I would see if I could have found you
the numbers for beef on this but I want
to put this graphic up because of the
work that we have done in North Carolina
related to the technology development
there has been a lot of interest
directed towards our initiative from all
over the globe and you if you look at us
compared to pork or poultry to other
parts of the world China in particular
you can understand that there is a lot
of growth and there is a lot of desire
to grow and a lot of parts of the world
have the same or they should have the
same environmental issues that we have
here and we have repeatedly then had
collaborations with people in China Asia
Australia Europe to some degree but
that's the the dynamics in Europe is a
little bit different related to animal
production agriculture and policy than
these other parts of the world
so I wanted to point that out because
there's interest in what we're doing
relative to technology implementation in
other parts of the world that in China
for example they currently are producing
half the pigs that are grown in the
world and they want to increase that
number dramatically and and they are
having environmental issues and one
thing one point that I want to make with
you is that and this isn't one of the
areas that I have gotten yelled at by
some of the stakeholders you really need
to think about sustainability in
multiple generations I think you need to
think about it as a minimum five
generations from now not next year or
next decade or next generation but
multiple generations in advance and you
have to consider it from a global
perspective I tell my students that on
the and I'm from a conservative state
and and this is one area another area
that I have been yelled at about but on
the global warming issue it's not a
question of whether it's real it's a
question of whether we're going to do
something about it or we're gonna learn
to live with the consequences and if
your policy is to move animal production
agriculture from one part of the world
to another just because of differing
environmental regulations that make it
easier to grow the animals there that is
not a good idea
that's that's true now I don't know the
percent of that but there are American
companies that have a significant
presence in China not to my knowledge
and and this is where we start to talk
about the environmental sustainability
issues and and this would be true for
poultry beef dairy the example here is
swine if you look at what has happened
in North Carolina I showed you these
numbers earlier in 1991 we had you know
about two and a half to three million
pigs on the ground and buy and now it's
ten million in 1970 the actual number of
farms was twenty thousand and now the
actual number of farms on the ground in
North Carolina are two thousand and you
see this trend worldwide for all of the
livestock and poultry production
commodities larger operations fewer
farms more concentrated production it is
happening worldwide we can discuss and
we can debate whether that is good or
not if your objective is to grow the
product as cost efficient as possible
and also as nutritionally productive as
possible and also as pathogen reduced as
possible the concentrated animal
production model if you look at this
objectively often
is the much better model as compared to
the smaller facilities and I'll I'm
teaching a course this semester an
honors course and the topic is
surrounding the controversial use of
sub-therapeutic antibiotics in animal
production agriculture and one of my
invited speakers who was not a
veterinarian for a company but he was an
academic veterinarian he made the
comment that he will not purchase pork
that is from certain chains because they
are only getting local grown free-range
animals and he said there started we are
now starting to see trichinosis in those
populations again and so there it is it
is an issue it is a consideration that
you need to think about and I understand
that it is very very controversial now
this is the slide that I want to make
some comparisons related to your topic
I've incorporated several visuals of
cattle and dairy feed Lots here visual
one two four and five are all with that
commodity and this visual is one of the
forms that we use as a control site with
our technology performance verification
work and this is a compost facility that
is a technology application and I want
to make the distinction there that you
have two considerations with all of
these commodities is some liquid waste
stream and a solid waste stream and the
way that you treat them from a
technology perspective would be
different in most cases well
the dairy and cattle operations this is
a holding retention runoff retention
facility associated with a cattle
feedlot so when you see these and these
and these you are going to have these
associated with it and you're going to
also in most environments be collecting
the solids from the waste from the dairy
operations and the cattle operations
that could then be further processed and
a composting or other type of treatment
for solids application I'm not a big fan
of composting it it is it's okay there
are some benefits you will kill the
pathogens as you're going to hear me
talk about a little bit later I've got a
real issue with ammonia emissions and
composting operations you're definitely
going to be losing ammonia from
composting operations but in these types
of environments with the animals and the
the the waste that is being produced and
the way that the waste is being held the
slurry being held in these open
environments whether it is this type of
retention pond with a cattle operation
or a so-called Lagoon with a a swine
operation this this is a swine operation
in North Carolina from the actual
surfaces and especially if you get some
so when current across the surface of
this this Lagoon or this holding area
and especially from within the buildings
you are losing tremendous amounts of
ammonia we are losing metric tons of
ammonia from these livestock and poultry
operations and I'm going to tell you a
little bit later why I think that is
such a big issue I think it is one of
the main contributing issues to why
these types of systems are not
generationally sustainable
it's the ammonia emissions it is that is
the big issue so let's talk about some
of the specific environmental parameters
that are not just North Carolina but
nationally that are either being
regulated or our emerging issues or are
being impacted by policy first are
nutrients and what I have done here is
put in the put in red some of the
parameters that are in my view emerging
issues of importance you're starting to
hear a lot more about it even with the
political climate that we have now in
Washington and in some of the states
surprisingly there's only one parameter
on this slide that represents the
majority of regulatory requirement for
livestock and poultry production in the
US and to a large degree of the world
it's the only one of them what do you
think it is
no EPA doesn't even regulate owner it's
the most probably the most controversial
one but from a regular if I am a
produced that it's producing these
millions and billions of animals I have
to go out and get I'm an a foe and I
have to go out and get from my state or
from EPA a permit which one of these do
you think drives that drink its
nutrients and which one of those
nutrients do you think it is
it's nitrogen its nitrogen
most of the permit requirements are
going to be based on land application of
nitrogen from the animal waste that
would be
based on the ability of the receiving
crop to assimilate that nitrogen so it
could be an advantage to a producer to
be volatilizing a lot of ammonia before
it gets to the crop area the field that
you're going to apply for crop if you
are laying limited that's an issue in
some cases it will be nitrogen and
phosphorus but because of the phosphorus
content and because the majority of the
regulations are based on nitrogen and
this would be true for cattle you will
be accumulating phosphorus in high
concentrations in that land area where
you are applying that waste and this is
the second reason that I think the
current systems are not generationally
sustainable because at one time we did
not think that phosphorus transported
readily but phosphorus under certain
soil type conditions and under certain
concentrations can transport very
readily not as readily as nitrogen but
we'll transport and it will transport
laterally and we'll get into surface
waters and it will cause you trophic
ation most streams relative to
eutrophication are going to be more
sensitive to phosphorous than they are
nitrogen so that's that's an issue
metals copper and zinc when you add
higher than the nutritional requirement
of these two metals to livestock and
poultry you will increase feed
conversion rate and with it especially
with the current grain prices that is an
economically favorable equation because
these are inexpensive nutrients but
they're going to accumulate they're
going to be excreted by the animal and
they're going to be land applied along
with the nitrogen and like phosphorous
even more so than phosphorus they're not
going to transport out of that land area
and in certain concentrations if it
builds up to certain concentrations were
certain soil types and certain receiving
crops it can become toxic to the crop
and once you have heavy metal toxicity
that is very very difficult to remediate
it takes a long long time arsenic I have
in the red because that's that's an
emergent issue that's actually an issue
this just kind of been addressed our
arsenic is a component of some of the
antimicrobial pharmaceuticals that have
been used in the poultry industry these
pharmaceuticals are a very very
effective
coccidia stat however because of the
build-up of the arsenic the the company
that was producing this pharmaceutical
was purchased by Pfizer and Pfizer in my
view did not want the
the public bad publicity that would come
with that so they have mandated to be
taken off the market so you can no
longer use that compound in the poultry
industry pathogenic bacteria big topic
emerging topic is antibiotic resistance
because with a lot of these industries
there are considerable amounts of
sub-therapeutic antibiotics being used
being added to the feed because again in
the literature is very clear on this
from a nutritional perspective you will
get a very significant improved feed
conversion rate by adding
sub-therapeutic antibiotics to the feed
or the war and then the question becomes
what impact is that having on antibiotic
resistance development of antibiotic
resistant bacteria that may then get
into the population and impact human
health and I've have participated in
some epidemiology studies and I can tell
you this if you go sample these animal
feeding operations the those facilities
like I showed you in the earlier slide
with the cattle and the poultry in this
one you will find antibiotic resistant
bacteria there and you will find the the
antibiotics there as well there will be
they will be there in the actual wastes
excreta and part per million
concentrations if you sample the surface
waters around those areas or the shallow
aquifer you will find them in part per
trillion concentrations so then the
question becomes how much of a risk is
that because one of the speakers that I
had to this class that I'm teaching this
semester they showed a very detailed
lifecycle analysis that showed the
impact of adding the very low
concentrations of antibiotic to the feet
relative to the reduced amount of corn
crop you would need to raise soybean
crop you would need to raise diesel
fuels needed for transport it was very
very significant so then you have to
look at what other risk versus the
benefits because the risk are not zero I
think if you look at it objectively
relative in the epidemiology studies
that I have been involved with with
scientists from UNC School of Public
Health Duke University Wake Forest med
school we just didn't see the the
phenotype of the antibiotic resistant
that was on the farm getting into the
gut of the workers or the people living
on the farms but the risk is not zero
the risk is not zero ammonia emissions
let me talk about ammonia emissions I've
made the case that we're losing a lot of
ammonia from these operations why is it
so was it significant relative to
sustainability we did as part of our
study with looking at these various
technologies of cost-benefit analysis
because the question come always comes
up or should come up about the
externality cost associated with
livestock production again this is true
with cattle this is especially true with
cattle there's a lot of ammonia loss
from these cattle feedlots and the
surprising thing that I learned in the
cost-benefit analysis was that when we
compared when we monetized the cost to
society of nutrients metals pathogenic
bacteria odor and ammonia ammonia
trumped the other four by eighty fold
and the reason for that is because
ammonia in the atmosphere as I'm sure
several of you know will react with
acidic compounds and be converted to
fine particle particulates and if they
are can if it's converted to fine
particle particulate then when we
respire it there are health consequences
and the objective determination of the
cost of that is very significant so
that's why and one of you actually asked
this question it was a great question
that's that very question if you're
looking at these different criteria
which one is the most important relative
to which technology do you choose so I
always feel you have to put top priority
for that reason on reducing ammonia
emissions there's also the there's the
that they're the rules and regulations
at the state in the federal level but
then there's public perception and I can
tell you that public perception is
really driving practices in livestock
and poultry production now I had a
meeting I spent a lot of time with the
corporate people in these industries I
spend a lot of time with environmental
groups and the community groups but I
was in a meeting a couple of months ago
where one of the corporate managers of a
major animal food production industry
made the comment to me that you said you
know we're not so much worried about EPA
anymore the new EPA is wal-mart and
McDonald's into Polti and I found this
one because I knew that you had a
Chipotle exercise with with one of your
classes and again is that good or bad I
can tell you that it is having an impact
it's having an impact on the
these animals are produced and it has
having an impact much more significant
than anything that I have seen from a
public policy regulatory and rulemaking
process in the last two decades so again
in North Carolina when the moratorium
was implemented this is what the
legislature put in place they said if
you want to expand you must sing you
must eliminate the discharge of
nutrients nitrogen phosphorus to surface
and ground work for the other for the
North Carolina legislature said you must
significantly reduce each of these so
what has significantly reduced me and I
think this is an example of how public
policy plays out an interesting way
because then when we went to the
technology process development the
Attorney General's Office said well the
North Carolina legislature has already
enacted what the environmental
parameters are that's not a negotiable
item so in the process of looking at
these technologies we had to quantify
what significantly reduce means and then
once we did that it got incorporated in
a subsequent legislative session and we
went through the Environmental
Management Commission and was codified
into law so now we know exactly how many
kilograms of ammonia we have to reduce
we know exactly what the outer
reductions have to be we know exactly
how many Logue reductions we have to get
with pathogens so I used to be really
annoyed
when I was involved with this process
the technology development process of
what we had inherited from the
legislative body but then after I went
through it I said you know it really is
the way that it should work because the
elected officials should not have been
the ones quantifying those parameters it
needed to be people that were made up of
public health officials scientists
engineers and that's what we did so I
think that was a good example one of you
asked the question what was the drive in
and this was a great question what was
the driving force behind that company
Smithfield Foods putting up fifteen
million dollars to do these technology
developments and performance
verifications well the Attorney General
negotiated that amount with the company
and I think is safe to say that if the
company had not agreed to do that
they're probably at that time would have
been a class-action lawsuit of some type
that would have been put in place so for
the technology getting to the science
which takes a lot of resources
scientific research is expensive we were
provided a good chunk of resources to
develop technology and then objectively
determine how the technology impacted
these environmental parameters and also
we were mandated to determine what the
cost would be and it took us about five
years to do that but we looked at about
15 technologies that we took from start
to finish and we developed quantified
the performance standards and in these
technologies there's a variety of
applications from simple to complex
anaerobic digestion anaerobic digestion
that is done
ambient temperature mesophilic
temperature of thermophilic temperature
low solid concentration high solid
concentration nitrification
denitrification type systems solid
separation systems even constructed
wetlands which actually worked pretty
well but you you still are losing
appreciable ammonia from constructed
wetlands one of you indicated that this
recept wetland would be a good system to
look at because of his simplicity and
that's true we found of these systems
five that actually met the environmental
criteria and we found about four that
were on the bubble because the way this
was set up it had to meet all five of
the environmental criteria if it hit a
home run on four and just didn't miss
the fifth couldn't count it could not be
used to meet the moratorium exception
but that recept reciprocating wetland
system was low cost and I think with the
little value engineer and probably could
be made to meet the all five of those
criteria so let's let's look at the
systems that were shown to meet the
environmental standards and this again
would apply for cattle co-products or
waste products and I used in this
visuals such that if you go and look at
this report it's easily to find what the
the companies that were sponsoring the
work for the individual technology
developments and this was a peer
reviewed process we solicited proposals
from academic institutions industry
groups technology suppliers and
I appointed a scientific review panel
and we got about a hundred or so
proposals and from those we chose the we
chose 18 15 of them were taken to
completion and these this was the
company named super soils it's been
changing out to Tara blue but this is a
system in which the liquid slurry so you
could take the slurry coming off of
those cattle facilities and process it
in this system and I'm sure you would
get equal results it goes through a
polymer solid separation process to drop
out the solids to drop out the metals to
drop out the phosphorous organic ammonia
will stay in solution and then like a
small municipality system that ammonia
is nitrified that's one reason that's
expensive you have to provide energy to
do the aeration to get the nitrification
then it goes through an anaerobic
environment you've got plenty of carbon
from the animal waste so you get good
denitrification
so you're addressing them on your
emissions you converting it to nitrogen
gas and there's an argument well is that
the best thing to do shouldn't we be
converting it to something that one
could be more readily recycled as a
fertilizer instead of putting it back
into the atmosphere as nitrogen gas this
is a fluidized bed combustion each of
these for our technologies that only
treat the solid component the fluid I
bed combustion process is very similar
to the gasification of solids process
you can you can get an energy component
as part of the process the same way that
you get with anaerobic digestion to
convert it to methane to convert the
carbon to methane this is a high solid
anaerobic digester
most anaerobic digesters that you read
about are gonna be digesters that treat
a high liquid concentration in the three
to six maybe as high as 12 percent
solids range this one would almost treat
solids in the same concentration as you
would have in a compost in unit and the
end product is his methane which can
then be combusted and converted into
electricity with the generator but that
brings us back to another policy issue
and this is an area that I've been very
disappointed when we were doing this
project 2002 2005 I was confident that
by now we would have a good carbon
credit policy in the US and that we
would have good return for green energy
that was going back into the grid and it
just has not happened in North Carolina
we at least did get a renewable energy
portfolio standard finally passed in
about 2007 and it did have an earmark
that a certain component of the Green
Energy had to come from livestock but it
was very very low and it's also
structured such that there the Power
Purchase Agreements that the producers
have to enter into with the utilities
are very restrictive and trust me I have
been yelled at a lot by stating that
position a lot but it's true and I
invite anyone to look at it objectively
and I invite anyone to look at what has
happened and what's on the ground there
very very few of these on the ground in
north carolina and this is true
nationwide and i get it that this is a
more expensive way to generate
electricity and the utilities do not
want to bear that cost and that bid and
impact their shareholders but I also
feel that if your objective we look at
the impact of the economy to this
industry if you want to sustain the
industry why would you not provide some
incentives that would be beneficial to
not only the producers but all of the
other people associated with that
segment of the economy and it certainly
would be good for the environment but
I've been very very disappointed in in
both the carbon credit policy and the
green energy policy directions I think
we've got a long ways to go in this
country on that getting more into the
technical component a little bit I'm
going to show you cost and a lot of you
with your questions and comments picked
up on this this technology and that this
is now this is a super soil technology
that is now the they've changed their
name to Terra blue we are now in a third
generation of that technology because
it's expensive and our engineers have
taken an approach with the company and
we've actually got some state support to
do this to to try to apply value
engineering and get that cost down and
we've had some success it's still not
where we'd like for it to be but we have
brought the costs down but look at this
if you think back to that slide seven or
nine that I showed you that the lagoons
and the cattle Lots
this looks very different associated
with
the animal production units and it is
very effective in addressing the
environmental parameters that we have
targeted this was the generation two
that we worked with and I want to show
you this one because it gives you a
little better perspective of the actual
technology and this would be one of
about 15 livestock buildings that are on
that property and this is a relatively
small footprint to treat that waste
stream because let's let's play the
numbers game again if we go back to
let's choose your commodity topic cattle
per thousand felled live weight on a
daily basis and this does not include
any flush water on a daily basis fecal
material in urine how many panels are
going to be excreted per thousand pound
live weight who wants to make a guess
daily basis you saw the numbers you saw
the inventory we've got we got about a
hundred million on the ground per
thousand pounds on a daily basis how
many pounds of fecal material and urine
combined would be generated per cattle
thousand pail
so we've got 20 pounds you better roll I
got to have a number from you you know
I'm not sure I can answer that question
definitively for cattle I can tell you
this the the nutrients that are consumed
by cattle the fee conversion is about
the worst it is the worst of all the
commodities that we've talked about
about other nutrients seventy to ninety
percent are going to be excreted it's
much less in poultry a lot lot less than
fish I know I saw that you had
aquaculture is one of your topics okay
we got 20 pounds in 100 pounds should
stop are you a head for for cattle it's
going to be it's going to be for beef
cattle it's going to be probably about
50 pounds for dairy it's going to be
probably closer to 80 to 90 pounds but
much higher for dairy so for swine
thousand pound yes the the the diet the
dietary component your objective with
the dairy is to is to generate milk not
meat so swine per thousand pounds live
weight fecal material in urine no flush
work per day
anybody want to guess it's interestingly
about the same as dairy it's about 90
pounds per day so getting back to the
point but we at this particular facility
5600 head average live weight per head
is going to be about 150 pounds on a
year to base year year-round basis state
of state live weight so you can do the
math and calculate how many kilograms
per day is going to have to go through
the system so it's that's a small
footprint it's a pretty small footprint
and and I have no research dollars or no
vested interest with super soils are
terribly just an overview of the results
and I put the reference in here all of
this work that we did we is published
its public domain and you can see there
it literally is thousands of pages with
these various reports and you can see
the various materials and methods and
the science behind how we derive these
numbers but look at these reductions on
carbon solid ammonia phosphorus
pathogens for log reduction odor
compounds almost 100 percent reduction
heavy metals almost 100 percent change
gears a little bit just just such that I
don't come across as promoting the super
soils of Terror blue system and this
system would also work for cattle it
would work for any type of system that
you would have a liquid slurry waste
coming off from and you definitely have
that with cattle this is a system that
uses an anaerobic digester that is
earthen low cost it's not tank as you
saw with some of the previous visuals
it's covered to make it an anaerobic
system
and then once the waste is treated it
comes out of the anaerobic digestion
unit into this baffled area of this
holding pond and then it is processed
through these trickling filters which
are these and one of the reasons the
super soil was so expensive was because
of the energy used to nitrified the
ammonia what it goes in the system and
one thing you will do with anaerobic
digestion systems as you will conserve
ammonia you're not going to be
volatilizing it which is good but you're
going to have it at some point that you
must treat it or it will volatilize so
to the researchers here said okay let's
use just a low energy trickling filter
with high surface area on beads within
the tanks of the nitrifying bacteria and
see if we can get night good night
efficient they did it worked quite well
it just couldn't get it quite to the
threshold that we needed to meet the
criteria this system met the odor
pathogen metals nutrient and met four of
the five so it didn't qualify and this
is another area on another value
engineering area that we're looking at
from an R&D perspective we have
continued to try to make these trickling
filters more efficient and I think we're
almost there okay well we'll zip through
well zip through the last two or three
but also with this system some of the
nutrients after it was nitrified was
used for vegetable production in these
greenhouses I want to show you this
because I know I saw that you also had a
tomato component and it was it worked
quite well work very well we work with
the School of Public Health that UNC our
big basketball rival to to look at the
pathogens and they found that there
essentially were no pathogens
transmitted to these Tomatoes Mark's
opsi who led that
study from UNC he said tomatoes that you
purchased in the market get but many
more pathogens on it from the people
that pick them up and put them back down
than they were getting from this system
I put this fight in because I wanted you
to see the beauty of the science I mean
this this is a tough issue but science
is really exciting it's really exciting
and in this system we work with sous
chef Minh at Duke University to do the
odor modeling and she used an alluring
Lagrangian model and actually on each of
the farms each of the farm systems that
we looked at if you were looking down
from above she modeled this such that
you were looking at ten meter squares
and in each point and this was based on
odor panel analysis and samples that
were taken she developed this model
where y would be the number of odor
parcels that were released from a point
on that 10 meter square and then you
could model the dispersion and X would
be the odor panel determination from 0
to 8 zero is no odor hate as extremely
offensive odor so and then we looked at
it because we had to take into
consideration property lines so we
looked at it east west north and south
so in this model if you look at this
this south orientation would be the
south orientation of this overhead shot
here and this one two three four five
six buildings would be the one two three
four five six buildings it's all red
intense odor inside the building as you
would anticipate but then when the wind
was coming from that direction you can
see how quickly it dispersed by distance
and that's pretty good this one actually
met the odor standards for the criteria
but as it isn't that neat science so
again they this technology was one low
cost
it did really well on everything except
ammonia and that's and we're working on
that component now and I think again I
think we're almost there
economic feasibility determination the
bullets in black or what we were
mandated to do with the Attorney General
agreement for all of these technologies
and as that essentially is a cost
returns analysis the controversial
component was what is in blue I agreed
that we would do a cost-benefit analysis
that was I had no idea how controversial
that would be but I stand by it I think
you have to do the externality cost to
monetize the impact to society and these
are the numbers but these are the cost
returns numbers we were prevented by the
structure of the agreement for putting
in the externality cost so you can see
with the baseline system is about $90
these economists drive me crazy getting
these values down to the penny but you
can see the this is generation 1 it was
much more expensive the generation 2
they knocked off about $100 on the unit
cost and I'm looking at some modified
numbers with some assumptions that we
think we're going to meet with the third
generation and I think we're going to be
getting close now per the mandate per
the law per the agreement we don't have
to get to that but we do have to get it
down to about 115 and that's some that's
a different discussion because we had to
go through the economic feasibility
determination and at the end of the day
we made a determination that at this
cost you can put no more than these many
people out of business or reduce the
herd size
by this value and that value was
determined to be 12 percent of the total
herd size again that was that was a
tough process to work through and
believe me not everyone agreed with that
12 percent some thought it should be 50
some thought it should be zero so what
have I learned in dealing with this for
two decades and and I'm not bragging
about this but I have been in some tough
situations I have had my life threatened
dealing with this topic real threats at
the end of the day I think you have to
look at the triple bottom line yes these
jobs in the economy do matter to these
people the cost to society do matter you
have to consider the externality cost
and of course the environment matters
that's where I have gotten in trouble
with the industry side it's not
sustainable I don't think there is
there's some problem areas but I don't
think there's real crisis areas right
now but if you look at it generationally
it is not sustainable and it is gonna be
some serious consequences if we don't
address it so with that I'll take
questions
and I think I've been told I have to
turn this off now